81% des sympathisants gilet jaune aimera
oups on à l'ars eu un attachement d'une
population qui est fragile qu'il a des
difficultés économiques qui est chauffé
à blanc qui a des difficultés
financières importantes parce que les
gilets jaunes sont souvent des gens qui
sont des petits indépendants qui n'ont
pas un salaire fixe et souvent des gens
qui ont des difficultés financières et
qui ont besoin de retravailler de façon
urgente
donc il ya un désir d'avoir une solution
c'est terrible de ne pas avoir de
solution et puis raul tu as une figure
de sauveur et on voit que je ne compare
pas du tout didier raoul trap est un
mets dans l'attachement à didier raoul
ton retrouve les ressorts de l'adoration
des français à l'été 40 pour pétain la
figure paternelle rassurante
le druide les racines françaises le
sauveur il y a là un retour à
l'attachement au chef au sauveur
il ya une dimension quasi religieuse je
suis assez actif sur twitter
et ce qui me vaut de recevoir quelques
milliers de messages d'insultés par jour
parce que je ne suis pas tellement pros
raul tu es je vois la détresse des gens
les gens pensent que quand on est anti
raul ton est un assassin les gens sont
sincèrement persuadés que la chloroquine
soigné et guéri la quasi-totalité des
malades
ils ne comprennent pas pourquoi faut
faire des essais cliniques les chiffres
qui ont été habilement manipulé par
didier raoul qu ils ne savent pas les
lire et les interpréter ils n'ont pas
bien compris que didier raoul tu as
récupéré des malades très jeune très peu
graves qui ont fait la queue pendant
plusieurs heures devant lier achu ya
aucun obèses quand on regarde les photos
des gens qui l'a inclus dans ses études
il ya personne avec un déambulateur ya
aucun vieillard il ya aucun n'y a pas de
malades chroniques et le score de
gravité des patients qui l'a inclus est
extrêmement faible
73 9% ou encore new skies et qui mesure
la gravité des malades qui est à 0 c
sont des gens comme vous et moi
donc oui dédiera holt a en apparence des
chiffres formidable mais qui
correspondent au fait qu'il a récupéré
des malades qui n'était pas vraiment
malade
c'est d'ailleurs ce que remarque de fait
sont acerbes la presse scientifique
internationale qui commence à se
de la gueule de l' expertise française
[Musique]